[Music]  good  what is this place what's your name  honey I'm Joe I teach middle school band  how'd it go for today started out as the  best day of my life  back here tonight first shows at 7:00  you know what this a must have been  Sutton for you  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  huh no it's the great before this is  where new Souls get their personalities  quirks and interest before they go to  earth  may 22 know everything about earth and I  don't want anything to do with it you're  missing out on the joys of life like  pizza I can't smell we can't we can't  taste either all that stuff is in your  body no smell no taste or touch see okay  [Music]  is all this living really worth dying  for  your song eyes can you help me get back  [Music]  mmm they sweet what is it  151,000 Saul's going to the great beyond  everyday you know I can't easily single  one of them  the counts off  [Music]